-Now, here's how it works.
We're going to have a normal
conversation with each other
except every so often, we're
going to hear this "ding" sound.
[ Ding ]
And when we hear that,
we'll be given
an emotion or situation
that we have to act out
as we keep talking.
-Okay.
-Sound good?
-Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
Alright. It's the first week
of October.
Do you already have
Halloween plans?
[ Ding ]
-Why are you asking?
-Why -- Why are you asking
-I'm ask-- You came --
Why would you do that?
-It's Halloween.
So you dress up, right?
Is that what you do?
Do you get candy?
-Do you dress up?
-Do you get can--
You get candy, right?
-Ca-- Is that like a code word
for something else?
[ Laughter ]
-Do you give candy,
or do you get candy?
-I --
I take it.
-Yeah.
[ Ding ]
Yeah.
You do? You take it?
[ Laughter ]
-I can't believe it!
-I know, there's
all sorts of candies!
You get uh, uh, chocolate bars
-Chocolate bars?
I love chocolate bars!
-I love it, too!
-What kind do you love?
-I love -- I love Hershey bars
-Oh, my goodness!
That's one of my favorites
-Oh, my God! Are you serious
-Oh, my goodness!
You say "serious"!
-Oh, my gosh!
I said the word "serious"!
-Oh, my God! You said "serious"!
[ Ding ]
-I've never said that before
But I'm good at being serious.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm focused,
and I'm a team player.
-Yeah, so am I.
I think I'm very eligible
for Halloween.
[ Laughter ]
And --
-I can wear all sorts
of costumes if you --
or none -- none if you don't
want me to wear a costume.
I'm flexible --
[ Ding ]
Either way and --
[ Shakily ] And if I --
If I dress up --
-Go ahead.
-If I dress up as SpongeBob --
-Oh, my God.
[ Laughter ]
SpongeBob?
-Yeah, if I dress up --
-You know, I just --
I just need a second.
Because I can't believe it
that I'm here with you.
And I just -- Oh, my God!
Don't touch me right now!
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding ]
-Uh, you don't --
You don't want me to touch you
[ Laughter ]
-I just feel like
maybe it wouldn't be right
-Well, I thought, like,
maybe you were, like, getting,
you know, too emotional
about the holiday.
So maybe?
-Yeah --
-I thought
maybe I could comfort you.
-That's possible.
But, you know, I feel like
sometimes you should ask, maybe?
Before --
[ Ding ]
-Do I have to? Because when --
In this society, 2019...
[ Laughter ]
...you know, men, women,
are they the same?
Do they get paid the same?
No. That's not fair.
How about this? Switch roles
How about walk a mile in
my shoes, maybe for a weekend?
No, literally, get in my shoes
-Because there are
about 75,000 people
that we know of on this bloc
alone who do not have shoes.
[ Laughter ]
And --
[ Ding ]
-Well, la-di-da.
[ Laughter ]
[ Ding, ding, ding ]
That's it right there.
We did it.
That was fun.
That was an emotional intervie
with Lupita Nyong'o.
Her new children's book "Sulwe
is available now for pre-order